this is the Tony Michaels podcast this
is the Republican party it always has
been real whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a
second I thought Republicans were for
freedom and raw they're the party of
white Christian nationalists they're the
party of real America First nazzi
political and social commentary the last
few days we've been talking about but
deodor and a few things this is Tony
Michaels Carlson isn't bad maybe I don't
um oh yeah he's irrelevant stop with all
the [__] stop with all the [__]
data and the polls No One Believes that
[__] even if it's true oh you guys are
being so extreme they're never going to
do that you know you talked about
condoms being you know banned as
contraceptives in a in a in a gas I
laugh I laugh because everyone thinks
I'm crazy I'm like what are you talking
about man do I want Ronda santis in the
race [__] yeah I do do I want Donald
Trump in race [__] yeah I do do I want
Donald Trump to have to continue to make
excuses and cancel his rallies and Ronda
santis weirdly show up in those same
areas and give us photo after photo
video after video of how awkward that
[__] is yes that is what I want
I am taking credit for the fact that I
annoyed George Santos so [__] much
yesterday by my calling my incent
calling to get a quote from George
Santos on his federal charges that he
turned his phone off and his phone off
this is a gift that Joe Biden has given
us this is a gift that Kevin McCarthy
fell ass backwards into he doesn't just
know it yet and the only reason why he
did this Kevin McCarthy
because because he wanted to save his
job like that should be just all the
evidence you need to get rid of Kim
Paxton you don't need any other bribery
or [__] obstruction of justice
charges just Trump and Ted Cruz is
supporting him at the same time cuz he's
a criminal is enough for me as if I
needed to say this out loud but what you
should say when you see Nazis goes Nazis
bad I don't like Nazis you should not
say hey those Nazis are not actual real
Nazis we're real Nazis those guys are
not real Nazis those are F real Nazis
would you can have your bigoted [__]
views your racist bigoted views you
can't act on them those are [__] hate
crimes but you can have your bigoted
[__] VI people in out there in the
country aren't paying attention aren't
listening although they should they
should come here here right here at the
Tony Michaels podcast every single
weekday